Student Kevin Troy asks, we’ve seen in this unit
the use of import time to get access to time the
clock. Can you talk about the basics of libraries,
what they are and how they work et cetera?
Okay, this is good because I don’t think I
explained really what’s going on when I use that.
What import does is just bring a library into your
execution environment, so you can have a
library that defines different variables, defines
functions, defines anything that you would define
in your own Python code and then when you
import it you get access to all of that but it’s not
in your own file. And having libraries is really
useful. It limits the size of the file that you have
to deal with, it protects the name space, so if
everything that was defined as part of the
standard library was always available and you
didn’t have to import it, there would be name,
more names that you have to worry about using
because they already have some other
predefined meaning.
So libraries are really useful. You can make your
own libraries, we’re not going to cover that and I’ll
see as one-on-one but as you start to build bigger
programs it’s really important to think about how
do you structure your program, so you don’t end
up with one huge file with lots of code that no one
can figure out what’s going on. So libraries are
very useful way to do that.